welcome to this tutorial on you know
data and
tools to model pa systems everybody um
we're happy to be presenting at the pi
data global 2021 and hope this you know
content will shine some light
into the amazing research that is going
on uh in the bb world and
showcase some of the cool projects
which have an overlap of
solar and data science and also you know
introduce you all to the
some of the basic concepts of pv
modeling via a
python package called pv lib
um my name is abhishek and i will be
presenting this content
along with you know kevin and mark um
silvana unfortunately could not join the
call but she is actually one of them you
know one of the ones to spearhead this
tutorial and um without her this session
would not have happened so yeah thanks
evan
um cool
so uh here's what we are going to go
over uh today
the first section uh will you offer some
motivation for solar photovoltaics in
general
and uh you know why do we need to model
pv systems
uh you know since the field is immensely
going uh it's offering like very
exciting data challenges
and i'll go over some of the interesting
challenges the pve community has been
trying to you know tackle using python
uh machine learning
image processing etc
uh then we'll jump into you know the
tutorials uh so there are three
tutorials in this session
uh the first tutorial goes over you know
some some of the very basic concepts and
steps involved
in pv uh systems um
and basically
we will be introducing you to the python
package
preview
the second tutorial will you know go
over
how much sunlight a pv panel receives um
and then we'll wrap up with the third
tutorial which shows how to calculate
you know the
power output of a pv system
uh using a very basic model but pretty
you know pretty powerful model called pv
bots
okay uh so yeah let's start with some
motivation so just in case if you are
not
in this solar bandwagon yet you know
solar pv installation has drastically
increased
in the last decade uh as you can see in
this plot um you know there are a few
reasons for this uh one of one of the
main ones is that solar has become very
economic
uh and actually it's you know even
cheaper than fossil fuels in some other
cases
so that's why you know homeowners
businesses and
utilities you know have adopted solar in
their portfolio
uh one of the other main advantage of
solar pv is that it is renewable
and clean source of energy
this means it reduces the greenhouse gas
emissions
uh which are you know all the causes for
global warming
and
uh
one another big advantage of solar is
that it's very scalable so you could
have a small system as few as you know
few kilowatts uh powering a small house
uh to hundreds of megawatts which can
power you know entire cities so
uh you know these are one of the few
factors why you know solar has seen a
drastic increase along with some other
renewable technologies out there
um okay so with this you know increase
uh increasing
in penetration of solar it has brought
some interesting opportunities um
uh you know in terms of labor
so we can see the you know from it it's
a plot showing how much contribution
solar is you know giving in
the percentage of the jobs renewables
have
so humans have been researching you know
efficient cell technologies better way
to
construct solar modules
and smarter ways to install them and you
actually provide om services for the pv
systems out there so all these you know
different aspects of solar industry has
kind of helped in increasing the labor
um okay so
this this is a very interesting and very
famous chart uh you know put together by
enroll
it shows the amazing journey pv
technology has taken in improving the
cell efficiency
um
it you know just shows
that there are
you know there are many different kind
of pve
uh technologies out there um so
one of one of the main ones is silicon
which is you know as of as of today's
having almost 90 percent of the market
but it's you know one of the
technologies out there
we have some other technologies such as
the
multi junctions in purple
if you see in the right top
of the chart
uh yeah that technology has dominated
the space applications where the
cells
are almost like 47 48 percent efficient
uh we also have the thin film
technologies uh which which basically is
the
line in the green the lines in the green
they they have captured a decent market
share of eight to ten percent uh
specifically you know the cadmium
telluride
uh models manufactured by first solar
and then in the red lines you know we
have some of the emerging pv
technologies um
you know
it's a different material uh based on
perovskites
they have shown promising efficiencies
uh but we are currently
uh researching on extending their you
know
lifetime and improving the reliability
so overall you know this this chart is
you know showing a very
very nice and very interesting journey
tv technology has taken over the last
few decades
um
all right so
along with this improving efficiencies
you know the costs of pv systems have
also come down drastically
the plots over here you know show that
so that i'll show the
cost of pa systems in dollar per watt
so it not only shows the significant
decrease in costs of pu systems but more
importantly shows you know how in pv
system the module itself is
one of the smallest costs
and so there are a lot of opportunities
for cost reduction and improvements in
other areas such as the soft costs you
know
making installation easier and more
reliable
um all the structural electrical
components um
etc
uh
moving on so this slide you know is is
basically showing how how wide the reach
of solar is actually
so right from the basic science you know
which involves um you know research in
materials and chemistry to make better
materials for pv cells
to model manufacturing which involves
you know fields of optics electrical
engineering mechanical engineering the
construction of uh systems and there
they have there are like lot of fields
you know
which which solar you know touches so um
there's huge scope for you know kind of
collaboration out there
fields not only from engineering and
sciences but also you know from
humanities and business uh tie in for
installations adoption of solar
community adoption etc so this is just
the tip of the field you know and there
are a ton of multi-disciplinary topics
of research that can be further explored
um
you know renewables need smart points
from different disciplines to push the
envelope on solar such as you know solar
plus
you you have multiple
uh other
aspects which which can be tied in with
solar so you have solar plus agriculture
which
um
which which can be which is typically
termed as aggregate voltaics where you
have huge lands you know filled with
both solar and
agriculture activities
um
you can look into machine learning uh
internet of things
electric cars and you know
storage itself so
i'm sure you know most of you would have
heard of
the tesla wall
where you know we combine the
we we couple the solar panels with
the the energy storage and you know it
can result into very interesting systems
all right so uh let me just jump into
some of the
cool projects you know the pv community
has been
trying to tackle so
this is a very interesting project the
you know taken by kristen perry at
andrew uh it does the automatic
recognition of configurations of the
photovoltaic fields out there using
machine learning so she's using some
very interesting image processing um the
reason why we have to do this is a lot
of times we get production data for
systems but but in a very little record
of how things are actually installed on
the field
and you know this is one of the cool
projects which does that um
without any data available you know
purely based on image recognition
uh this is another example of you know
machine learning uh where we are using
natural language processing to parse the
filled
nodes of repair um so when the
maintenance is performed you know often
there's not a standardized way to
document uh the nodes and
you know
this
project basically
leverages the power of nlp
to predict you know how the
why we are losing the production uh
based on the notes taken from the field
um this is you know another cool cool
project you know done by silvana
she developed an open source program to
use parallelization to perform ray
tracing
uh it's basically optical modeling of
how the light moves through
uh from the sky to pv system and you
know it's basically done to calculate
the pv performance uh ray tracing is
very computationally intensive and you
know this visualization
uh
just shows you how it's done um
[Music]
this this youtube video is just kind of
showing
how
the the weather changes uh across the
entire us
uh it's basically
a time lapse of
the year 2018 showing
the top two figures are showing the
resource solar resource and the bottom
left is showing the temperature how it's
changing
and then the bottom right shows the wind
speed
um
yeah with with so you know the the whole
point is that there are like a lot of
cool interesting projects uh what can
you think about when it comes to solar
and data so this was just you know was
to serve as a motivation to jump into uh
some some kind of you know pv plus data
science activities
so with that i think i'll you know just
hand over to my um
my colleague mark
uh who will help you to set up
the um
the you know the jupiter hub basically
to get started with the tutorials
all right
so um
i'm going to paste
this github repository
into the chat and i'll also post it on
the slack channel
uh we're going to scroll down to the
readme
anybody can visit this site anytime
um
and once again my name is mark mccoskey
and the um
the announcer already kind of gave my
bio um so we're going to scroll down to
the section that says tutorial setup
so these tutorials are designed to run
in jupiter
um
and basically that's a way to run python
in a browser
and then we have set up a jupiter hub
uh server at this address here so it's a
stu two-step process to get to these
tutorials um
first
uh what i need you all to do is visit
the jupiter hub server which i'm going
to paste into the chat
so when you get to this site you're
going to see
this sign in image here
so
um put any username you want and any
password you want i think you can even
leave password blank but then um
you won't have a password
um you can create new accounts if you
need to
um it doesn't really matter so i already
have one account so i'm going to log in
so once you log in you'll probably just
see scratch and shared data
so hopefully everybody's at that step so
click this link
you'll be shown this login screen enter
username password if you choose and then
the first time you log in you will see
scratch and shared data
so can give me a thumbs up
or if you have any questions
um
feel free to post them in the chat or in
slack
so then the next step is to click this
next link here which i'm going to paste
in the chat as well
and this uses oops that did not work
let's try again
this uses a super cool open source
project uh
called
[Music]
nb git puller thank you
um
and what it's gonna do is it's gonna now
that you have this um
account created on our jupiter herb
server
um it's going to pull
um
that repository which i'm showing to you
right now this one
which is pi data 2021 into your
jupyterhub
environment so if i paste this in here
you're going to see it
syncing git repository before sending
you and voila here we are now we have
the tutorial open
um
so let's see
after that you're going to be in this
folder page
and uh we're actually going to skip a
few
of these tutorials um
one thing i wanted to say before
uh is um
i think i might have mentioned this
actually already um
so
if you have any questions you know ask
in the chat here or also in slack um and
this is also being recorded
um
okay so i think we are going to go
straight into
tutorial one
so i'm gonna go back to my jupiter hub
page and the tutorials are are numbered
here
so this is tutorial one
uh
okay we're all on tutorial one weather
data accessing it and understanding and
visualizing it
um
just so you know this this this server
is running on um an azure virtual
machine
uh instance with 16 cores and 64
gigabytes of ram i honestly don't know
how many people are attending so um
hopefully we won't have any uh problems
i sometimes note that the pictures don't
show up and this spins for a little
while if that happens i just kind of
stop and start it again and then it
seems to get them
ta-da okay
so um
i think we are all good to go
um one last thing i kind of wanted to
cover is as i mentioned uh when you
click the second link
um
we're using the nb
uh git puller which you know pulls this
repository in this branch um and this
basically assumes that any changes you
make
in here are things that you want to keep
um so um if you do make any changes to
these for example today we're going to
run these so your output will change
then when you go to run nb goodpuller it
actually won't pull the tip
of whatever the upstream main branch is
anymore so what you can do is go back
here and just delete everything out of
here
and as you saw me kind of quickly do it
uh
fast way to do that is to
open up this terminal
and you know delete it using kind of
linux commands like you know rm
rf pi data block and it'll just be gone
um so if you another quick easy way to
kind of get around that is just make a
new profile you know that'll that'll
work too um and there's there's well
there's no really no limit to the number
of profiles you can have so
all right so
let me see the other things on here
[Music]
there is also a jupiter book document
that you can access that has all this
content
so after the
tutorial if you ever want to come back
to this it's all here it's the same
thing and this will also point you to
the jupiter hub
or start a my binder instance or go back
to the repository
um
and uh
so um
and then uh
you can also always run this on my
binder here just by clicking this my
binder link and there's also
instructions for running it locally
people may have to click the not trusted
box and convert it to a trusted one in
the top right of the notebook thank you
avi to everyone so yeah so if anybody
has that issue
uh
just let me execute
yeah i'm not sure if this is fully
necessary i've never done it but um if
you want to do it go for it uh okay so
with that i'm gonna hand it off to the
next speaker
um which is um
kevin
take it away kevin
yeah thanks mark let me
get set up here
so uh like mark said uh we're going to
be starting with tutorial one
and i already have this open if you
don't already have it open then from the
root of this uh jupiter hub if you just
click tutorial one it'll open it in a
new tab here for you
so
oh and before we we dive too far into
the code here i want to uh plug that pv
lib has a google group and and
that's the sort of user support forum
and so if you're interested in using
pblib after this presentation uh the
google group is a great place to be and
we're all very friendly and happy to
answer questions so in case um in case
this piques your interest go check that
out
so jumping right in tutorial one is all
about weather data and probably
unsurprisingly uh weather data is quite
important when you're modeling pv
systems
unlike sort of traditional generators
like coal plants or natural gas or any
of those which um
you know if you run out of coal you can
just bring in more
uh something like a solar farm is
dependent on
uh what weather is available and if it's
a cloudy day then uh the system is
probably not gonna produce very well so
weather data is very important uh people
in the pv space spend a lot of time
thinking about weather data and so
that's what this first tutorial is about
accessing it where you can find weather
data sets online many of them are high
quality and publicly available
even to hobbyists
uh understanding what the relevant
weather variables are and so uh
irradiance or sunlight is obviously a
big one but some other ones are relevant
as well
and then um you know how you can use
this with with existing python tools
so scrolling down uh oftentimes weather
data is is measured with these fancy
uh you know space looking
instruments these measure the intensity
of of sunlight in in various ways um
you can also get weather data from
satellite based models so models that
use imagery from weather satellites and
then simulate what they think the
weather was that corresponds to that
imagery those are very powerful because
they apply to many different locations
you don't have to have an actual weather
station at the location of interest and
so there's a few different types of
weather data
in terms of how to produce it once you
have some weather data
a very popular way of dealing with it in
a pv modeling context is what's called a
typical meteorological year
and
the goal here is to solve the problem of
every year is different when it comes to
weather and so for example it's
you know october 29th it's pretty sunny
here where i am in colorado today but
october 29th last year might have been
might have been cloudy right so
obviously no two years are going to be
exactly the same
and in particular some years just might
be a little bit sunnier than others just
because there's a random weather
variation
and so
a typical meteorological year is it's
sort of a synthetic year in the sense
that it never actually happened this is
not a specific year like 2020 or 2019
um
but a tmy is built from real data and so
for example if you have 20 years of
historical weather data uh you look at
every every january all of the 20
januaries that you have on record and
pick the one that's kind of in the
middle of the distribution when it comes
to irradiance
or sunlight or temperature or whatever
else you're interested in and you do
that for every month and you can
assemble what's called a typical
meteorological year and so this won't
reflect any actual year exactly but
it'll get you kind of close to a
long-term
average
and teamwise are really popular and
we'll be using tmys for the rest of this
tutorial
so i apologize in advance if i use too
many acronyms um there's a lot of them
in the pv world i'll try to avoid them
where possible so like i mentioned uh
all uh pv lid is is a python package it
integrates really well with the existing
pi data stack um especially it
integrates well with pandas because of
the nature of pv modeling is usually
centered around time series data and so
pandas is a really convenient way to
handle that
uh first up
uh we'll be reading a tmy a typical
meteorological year data set using pvlib
and pvliv has functions for fetching
data from a lot of different places
from different places on the internet
from reading various file formats if you
have local weather files and things like
that
the first one we'll be using is called
read tmy3 and so tmy again is typical
meteorological year and three it's kind
of like version three of the tmy file
format there's been a few iterations of
it you can you can think of it like that
and uh if you're interested in the
documentation for this function you can
use the normal python docs we also have
online stocks on read the docs if you're
interested in
uh and the idea is uh this is just
reading a local file you give it a file
name and then there's a couple of
optional um inputs you can you can use
to
make uh just change what it returns a
little bit and what it returns is a
pandas data frame that has the time
series data contained in the file and
tmy files also include metadata about
the system or the weather station that
recorded the data
and so if we look at some of the some of
the variables that are returned no this
isn't rendering very well
well we'll look at this in a minute
so in this block of code what we're
doing is we are
reading a tmy3 file that is actually
shipped with pblib and so if you have
pvlip installed like this jupiter hub
does
then this tmy3 file is already there and
available for reading
uh and so we this data dir is just is
determining the directory or the folder
that that file lives in and then we give
that to
this read tmy3 function built into pvlib
and we get back a
data frame and a metadata dictionary
so mark's telling me something
yes i will zoom in
hopefully that's a little easier to read
so if we look at the metadata for this
for this tmy file tmys are specific to a
given location and so a tmy file from
one place won't won't necessarily be
accurate for another place this
particular tmy was recorded at the
greensboro airport which is in north
carolina in the united states and you've
got some latitude longitude and some
other metadata here
um so this is the metadata available if
we look at the time series data that's
in the data frame itself dft and y
then we can see some of the variables
that are included in this data set and
one of them is
is ghi and i'm gonna again stay away
from the acronyms here as much as
possible but i'll note that the i here
stands for irradiance and radiance is a
fancy word for sunlight basically
uh you have another one dni again the i
is a radiance and then there's some
other things in here um like pressure
you've got albedo which is how how
reflective the ground is basically
and and in total you can see that
there's 71 columns and so there's a lot
of data in this file and we're
definitely not going to talk about all
of it
71 columns and the other number here is
8760 that's the number of hours in a
year assuming it's not a leap year
anyways
and so um you always hear uh in in the
pd world everybody's always talking
about 8760s uh talking about hourly data
sets that cover one year
so since it's a pandas data frame you
can manipulate it like you would any
other pandas data frame uh this is uh
the pi data conference so i'm going to
assume that most of you are familiar
with with that
and again here's here's all of the
columns that are available a lot of
irradiances dhi the eye is irradiance
you got things like dry bulb temperature
which is just the ambient temperature
for that location wind speed and then
some other things that are relevant for
pv modeling
okay so let's talk about irradiance uh
radiance is is obviously the main driver
of of solar farm uh power conversion
and there's two main types of irradiance
and and we have to model them separately
the first is what's called direct
radiance which is light that's coming
directly from the sun
and it doesn't get uh you know it
doesn't hit a cloud on the way it
doesn't get dispersed by aerosols in the
atmosphere
um it's basically this is the light that
when you look at the sun and you get
your eyes burned this is the light
that's doing that
uh but that's not all of the light that
is available for a solar panel to use
you also have diffuse light uh which is
coming in from the rest of the sky dome
is what we call it just the rest of the
sky and so this is the light that makes
the sky blue um this is caused by
scattering off of off of dust and
aerosols and stuff in the atmosphere so
some beam irradiance gets converted to
diffuser radiance that way when i say
beam i mean direct that's that's the
same thing
on cloudy days basically all of the
director radiance gets converted to
diffuse because on cloudy days you can't
even really see where the sun is in the
sky and so director radiance must be
basically zero
and diffuser radiance is all there is um
if if you're a solar panel so so these
are the two components of interest
direct and diffuse and we'll be modeling
those separately
uh wind and air temperature are also
relevant uh despite you know obviously
we're not
talking about wind farms here
wind and temperature are relevant
because the operating temperature of a
solar panel
changes its efficiency and the hotter it
is the less efficient the solar panel
becomes
and so if you are interested in a very
detailed pv model then you're going to
be modeling the operating temperature of
the panel itself
and you have to model that based on
uh
based on the the ambient air temperature
which you might get from something like
a tmy3 file
uh and the wind speed wind provides a
small cooling effect
so that's why wind and temperature are
relevant it's for determining the
efficiency uh for each time stamp of of
your photovoltaic array
okay so
uh down selecting those 71 columns down
to the five that are really of interest
here we have three irradiance components
like i said and these are various um
direct and diffuse uh sort of sub
components of the overall
um sunlight you have dry bulb which is
ambient temperature and
wind speed and so these are measured the
three radius components are often
measured in uh watts per square meter
and if that doesn't immediately make
sense don't worry about it but it's sort
of a power density in terms of how much
sunlight is available per unit space and
so if you multiply
uh this irradiance in watts per square
meter times the number of square meters
of solar panels you have then you can
get an estimate of the total sunlight
hitting your array of the idea uh dry
bulb uh ambient temperatures usually
measurement celsius um and wind speed is
meters per second
so we can make some plots
uh i'm going to kind of blow through
these fairly quickly here like i
mentioned so so let's see dni that the d
in in dni stands for direct and so this
is the direct component coming directly
from the sun
and depending on these days so this is a
week of data here uh on some days
the director radiance is basically zero
and on some days it's really high almost
800 watts per square meter and so this
is showing what days are sunny and what
days are cloudy and on the cloudy days
you basically have no director radiance
and all of the irradiance that's
available to you is dhi which is diffuse
and that's the orange line plotted here
and you can make fancy plots that's all
matplotlib
uh to talk a little bit more about these
irradiance components so we've already
talked we've mentioned dni and dhi those
are the direct and diffuse horizontal
components
you also have what's called global
horizontal irradiance and
i don't i don't know how important it is
to really understand this fully but the
idea here is that you can measure
sunlight in different ways
and
it's useful for different applications
and so ghi the global horizontal
radiance is basically if you just point
an irradiance sensor straight up
and measure everything direct and
diffuse then that's what uh ghi is and
it's the g is global and that means
everything is the idea not just direct
or not just diffuse
uh so this is sort of an all-in sunlight
measurement
uh if you want to measure just diffuse
then what you do is you still point your
your um
irradiance sensor straight up and you
just put a little sunblock or a sun
shield uh in between the sensor and the
sun and it's small enough that most of
the sky is not obscured but the direct
radiance coming straight from the sun is
and then it gets blocked and so in that
way um
you're measuring only the diffuse
component
and if you flip this around you can
measure just the direct component by
putting your radian sensor sort of at
the bottom of a long thin tube and
pointing that tube directly at the sun
and so sunlight
is able to you know if it if it's
correctly aligned sunlight will go
straight down the tube and hit the
sensor but diffuse light from the
broader uh sky
is not aligned with that tube and so it
won't make it in so these are the
different ways that these components are
measured um in practice
okay
so here's some more plotting i think we
can safely skip this
uh the last step i want to do just a
little bit of comparisons on what you
can use tmy data for
even outside of the context of pv
modeling
and so for example if you want to
calculate the total
monthly sunlight for a given location to
see how sunlight varies seasonally and
so for example in the northern
hemisphere at least in the u.s
um we tend to get more radiance in the
summer than in the winter
and uh tmi data is a really easy way to
answer the question of well how much
more do we get in the summer compared
with the winter
and so for example since this is just a
pandas data frame uh you can it
re-samples very easily and so we can
resample to monthly and get the sum of
each irradiance in each time stamp
and when we plot that
uh you can see that in the winter at
least for this location in north
carolina uh we get even less than half
of the irradiance of of summer we get
less than half of that in the winter so
there's a lot of seasonal variation here
and uh you know to
put this in context back in the pv world
uh you don't just want electricity in
the summertime generally there's i mean
there's going to be some seasonal
aspects to demand
but even in the winter you still want
electricity and so when we are designing
pv systems we'll design it to kind of
smooth this out a little bit and maybe
design the system in such a way that we
will sacrifice some summertime
irradiance to boost our winter time
production
and we'll talk about that some more in
the next tutorial
uh we can also take monthly averages and
so here's uh comparing wind speed with
ambient temperature and so you can see
the wind speed tends to be higher in the
winter than in the summer for this
location which is cool because it means
that wind power is kind of complementary
to solar in a way so when solar is
producing a lot maybe wind isn't
producing so much but when solar isn't
producing then wind is producing a lot
and so they complement each other in
that way from a from a grid stability
standpoint
and obviously in the summertime in this
northern hemisphere location um
temperature is higher in the summer than
in the winter
so that's uh for
all of this was done using a tmy3 file
that ships with pvlib but that's just
one example file
and if you're interested in in the
greensboro airport then great probably
you're not and you're interested in
somewhere else so let's talk about where
you can get other weather data sets
there are many weather data sets
available some of them are free some of
them are
are commercial and paid for
uh the one that we'll be using in the
rest of these tutorials is uh what's
called the
nsrdb which is the national solar
radiation database and this is um
a weather data set produced by
nrel in the united states
and it covers much of north america and
some places outside of that but it's not
a global data set unfortunately
um this is free you can sign up for an
api key and um it's very easy to use
uh it's based on satellite and so you
can get it kind of anywhere within
any location in this colored range is
is available in the nsrdb
but there are lots of other ones uh we
won't be using any of these in this
tutorial but they're worth mentioning
just to just to let you know that they
exist um energy plus weather is more for
building simulations for like
you know air conditioning heating and
cooling type stuff but it's also useful
for solar modeling
uh pvgis is a product that's really
popular in
europe and again is another free data
source
here are some other ones uh that are are
commercial i think all of these are
commercial
probably they are
and so if you were financing a system
and you really wanted to be sure that
you're getting the best weather data you
might use some of these
okay uh like i said we're going to be
using the nsrdb for the rest of these
tutorials uh if you'd like to sign up
for an api key now it's very fast and
there's there's links in this notebook
for that
uh if you don't want to do that now then
that's okay and then there's sort of a
demo api key that's that's limited in
certain ways but we can still use it for
this tutorial if you want
uh so i'm going to pause for a little
bit here and and to give people time to
go and sign up for their key if they
like uh it's going to be just this
string of of you know gibberish
characters that we copy and paste into a
scripts later on just to give you um a
heads up on that
okay let's see what's going on in the
chat i have been paying attention
looks like mark's been on top of this
do those dbs come with coordinates or do
i have to get them elsewhere through an
id of the weather station or something
yeah good question so
for the weather data sets like the nsrdb
for example is based on satellite
weather and so there's not really any
weather stations that contribute to that
data set it's it's all based on
satellite imagery or mostly anyways and
so use it and the way that it works is
um and we have an example of this in
just a moment uh you give it
when you make this request to the api uh
you give it a latitude and longitude
that you're interested in and it just
gives you the weather data for that
location and so it doesn't have to
necessarily be associated with the
station
for databases that are based on actual
ground weather stations rather than
satellite data uh then yeah then then
it's based on a network of stations and
each station has an identifier and
coordinates and you can look up the one
that's closest to your location
so i'm going to assume that folks have
an api key or or are going to have one
before too long this cell there's kind
of a lot going on here uh if you have an
api key then you can just paste it right
there and so you put it in in single
quotes it's just a python string so you
know my key it's not going to be english
but you can just put it in there as a
normal python string if you don't have
one uh then there's then there's like i
said there's this demo key built into
this uh notebook
uh you probably shouldn't be using this
long term if you wanna if you're
interested in doing this in the future
but just for for this notebook it's
probably okay and you'll get away with
using that one
uh so like i was just saying
um the function that pv ships with for
accessing the nsrdd is called get psm3
psm is the physical solar model and
that's just one of the data sets
provided by the nsrdb
and you give it a latitude and a
longitude uh the nrel api key that we
configured in this cell above
uh the email that you signed up for the
api key with and then names represents
what data set you're interested in
and so here we're going to be using a
tmy
but
the nsrdb also has
single year data sets and so for example
if you wanted to model
a specific year for a system for example
to compare simulated production with
maybe actual production from a real
system or something like that
uh then you can request specific years
like if i put 2019 here and i would get
back um data set for 2019 rather than a
typical meteorological year
so if we run this
uh then again we have uh we get back a
metadata dictionary about
uh the location that our that our
weather data applies to and some other
things like what units it's in uh what
version of the data set this is very
important
and then we also have this data frame of
time series data and this is called
dfabq abq stands for albuquerque and
this is for
albuquerque which is a city in new
mexico in the united states
and it's just an example location
so now that we have our
uh time series data
what we can do is let's compare it with
uh
the data from that airport in north
carolina that we were looking at earlier
and so monthly ghi this was defined in a
cell
earlier when we're looking at
seasonality so that's still in this
session and we can compare it with our
new data from albuquerque and so we're
labeling this nc for north carolina and
nm for new mexico and so these are just
two locations
um north carolina you would expect to be
uh less sunny than new mexico because
new mexico is in the desert southwest in
the united states and so it's it's
hardly ever cloudy there it's very dry
and very sunny
and the irradiance data that we have uh
reflects that
and so again nm is new mexico here so
you can see that consistently across the
entire year uh new mexico gets more
sunlight per month than north carolina
does and especially in the summer time
it's a very big difference there and so
this difference is why i don't know if
you know the history of of solar
deployment in the us very well but the
desert southwest is really where a lot
of the early initial deployment was for
for solar photovoltaics and it's because
uh there's just a lot more solar
resource there to collect
but nowadays now that systems are so
cheap and so efficient um it makes a lot
of sense to deploy them in other places
like north carolina even though it maybe
has less sunlight overall than the sun
gear locations
okay so that's tutorial one
let's see any questions here before we
move on
i don't see anything in the chat
cool
okay so at this point we're going to
head on over to tutorial 2
which is called poa irradiance
i'll go ahead and open that one up
myself
this one is all about taking these
weather files
uh that are sort of a generic and not
really tied to us to a particular pv
system
and doing some modeling to
generate the irradiance that is actually
available for the pb system to harvest
you could say
and so poa irradiance
uh
i know i said i avoid acronyms here poa
stands for plane of array
and this is the it's the concept of the
irradiance that's hitting your solar
panel depends on where your solar panel
is pointing what part of the sky is
pointing at and if you point it directly
at the sun then it'll obviously be
getting a lot more radiance than if you
point it away from the sun
and so poa radiance the what this
tutorial focuses on is turning these
these three sort of generic irradiance
components that we saw in the previous
tutorial
uh turning that into
the irradiance uh that is that's hitting
an actual um solar panel at a specific
tilt and and orientation
so this is the main driver of pv system
power is the plane of array radiance and
so this is um a lot of attention in the
in the modeling world is given to
getting this modeling process correct
transposition is what this is called is
transposing
uh these three base components into the
plane of array irradiance
okay so
uh like i said i
the the irradiance that's hitting your
panels depends on where they're pointing
in the sky and so for any instance
depending on how well the sun is aligned
with these two arrays
one of them is probably going to be
getting more sunlight than the other one
and probably that's going to change not
only across a day as the sun moves
across the sky from east to west but
also seasonally because um
this where the sun is in the sky
basically how high it gets in the sky
changes with the seasons and uh where i
am in the northern hemisphere
uh
in the summer the sun gets high in the
sky whereas in the winter the sun stays
pretty close to the horizon even at noon
it's fairly low in the sky
and so
uh the the orientation of your panels
affects
production
not only
um on a day-by-day basis but also but
also seasonally
and so
and and this is what i was talking about
um with how well your panel is aligned
with the sun and so if you want to
produce a lot then basically what you're
doing is minimizing this angle of
incidence the aoi which is um just a
measure of how well your panel is
aligned with the sun and so if you
minimize this this angle then you're
pointing directly towards the sun as
much as possible and you'll be you'll be
getting the most arrangements
so when i say orientation what i mean by
that is um essentially it's it's defined
by what's called the tilt and the
azimuth
and the tilt is
uh how far above the horizon your panels
are facing and so if they're just
pointing straight up and that's tilt
equals zero and as you tilt your panels
more and more eventually they'll be
pointing directly towards the horizon so
the panel itself will be vertical and
that's at 90 degrees tilt
and and typically the tilt is somewhere
in between they're like 20 degrees or or
something like that
uh the other
coordinate is called azimuth
and this determines where
along the horizon your panel is facing
and so for example even if you're if
you're tilted at 20 degrees for example
you can be tilted 20 degrees facing
south or tilted 20 degrees facing west
or east or north or anywhere in between
and azimuth is a measure along the
horizon of um of what sort of compass
direction you're pointing and so azimuth
goes from zero to 360 degrees
uh technically tilts it usually goes
from zero to ninety i mean technically
it can be tilted facing down so i guess
i guess it goes zero to one eighty but
nobody actually does that and so you
have uh
so you measure
your
panel orientation with tilt and azimuth
and then uh
you you combine that with where the sun
is in the sky
uh which is measured in in a very
similar way again it's it's based on the
azimuth so where along the
along the horizon it is and then how
high in the sky it is
um you combine module orientation handle
orientation with solar position and then
you can figure out uh what your poa
gradients is
and so
we're going to be using that same tmy
data set from before just as an example
you could replace this really easily
with a data set pulled from the nsrdb if
you wanted to model a specific location
or you could use your own weather data
pulled from somewhere else
the new thing in this cell is this
location which is a pv lib object
that
basically just encodes a particular
location on the surface of the earth and
it has some some helper functions to
generate things like solar position for
that location
okay so we've got a we've got a location
and we we gave it the coordinates uh
that corresponds to our weather data set
because obviously those have to match or
else things are going to get wonky
next up we calculate the solar position
and this is very easy just
location.getsolarposition
and then you give it a list of
timestamps to calculate the solar
position for
and if we look at the variables that are
returned here
there's things like apparent zenith and
zenith apparent elevation elevation and
then you have azimuth and equation of
time azimuth we already talked about
that is again where along the horizon so
what compass direction the sun is um
elevation and cement are sort of
complements of each other they really
measure the same thing
i i think elevation is easier to think
about personally
elevation is how far above the horizon
the sun is at this moment in time and so
you can see that all of these numbers
are negative uh which means that it's
below the horizon and if you look at the
time stamps it's because it's in the
middle of the night and so once this
gets to dawn uh elevation will cross
zero and then it'll it'll go into the
positive numbers during the daytime
and so
uh you can think about elevation kind of
the same way you think about tilt for
the for the array orientation
okay so now
just recapping what we've done so far
we have the weather data for our
location
based on a tmy3 file and now we've
calculated solar positions for the same
time stamps
and these are both
data frames that are 8 760 elements long
because they reflect a single year
so if we
uh the only thing we're missing here is
the
panel orientation the panel tilt and the
panel azimuth
and for this example we're going to be
assuming a 20 degree
tilted panel
with azimuth equal to 180 and 180
degrees is south facing in the
conventions that we use
so those are the three really the three
inputs here are the panel orientation
encoded with those parameters
uh the weather data these are the three
irradiance components that we've been
talking about and then the solar
position that pvlib calculated for us
and we give those three uh inputs
or sets of inputs rather to this get
total irradiance function that pv lib
gives us and we get back a data frame
called dfpoa and again poa stands for
plane of array so this is the irradiance
that's
um in the plane of of the array that
we're simulating
and it's a data frame rather than a
series because there are several
components here
um i mentioned that we model direct and
diffuse components separately
and so um
uh
these are each of those components after
projecting it into the plane of array
poa global is the main one this is sort
of the all in total in planer radiance
so this is what we're going to be using
going forward
okay so uh what's the point of of
tilting your panels that's an unnatural
question that we get asked a lot
like why wouldn't i just put them flat
on the roof and like i mentioned uh the
panel orientation really has to match
the solar position
uh to to get good production and so by
operating at a tilt and again this
depends on where you are uh hemisphere
versus southern hemisphere and where you
are like basically your latitude but for
this specific location uh tilting at 20
degrees facing south
uh results in a fairly uh dramatic
change at least dramatic in my eyes in
in a radiance and so ghi again is sort
of the base that's the irradiance you'd
have if you just laid your panels flat
but if you put them at a tilt then you
get these orange bars instead and so in
the winter time you get a fairly
significant boost to production
uh or at least to sunlight collection
uh but it comes at a small cost in the
summer time because by operating at a
tilt uh in this location because the sun
gets so high in the sky in the
summertime
uh it's making the alignment worse in
the summer by improving it in the winter
and so this is a an optimization problem
basically where you just you decide
how much energy you want to produce at
what times of the year and then you can
optimize your tilts to
to generate that desired profile
and because pvlib is a python package
you can do this you know you can just
plug this basically straight into
scipy.optimize
or any of the other packages in the pi
data ecosystem to do that optimization
which is really cool because a lot of pv
tools
don't integrate with you know existing
um existing package ecosystems like that
and so that's really a strength of pv
lib is that it plays so nicely with with
i mean not only pandas and matplotlib
and all of that but even even more
specialized packages like like sci-fi
uh we can also make some more plots and
this is showing what i was saying where
this is a day in the winter and you can
see that the the in-planer radiance is a
lot um is a lot stronger than just the
horizontal radians
uh whereas in the summertime um it's a
it's a much smaller difference
we can also
model
uh
so that was for a simulation for a fixed
tilden azimuth panel and so maybe that's
on somebody's rooftop or it's on fixed
racking
but a lot of large-scale solar farms
nowadays are using what are called
trackers
and these are
dynamic moving structures that that
change the panel orientation
during uh you know across the day to
track the sun as it goes across the sky
and so
um
rather than having a single tilt like 20
degrees for example
now you have a time series tilt and a
time series azimuth that that changes
each time stamped based on where the sun
is
and pvlib has a function to calculate
the
tilts and azimuths of for tracking
systems uh single axis there's several
types of trackers single axis tracking
is the one that we'll be using today
and you give it the time series solar
positions and so again these are time
series inputs and we get back time
series output
and now we have this tracker data data
frame
and if we look at at this tracker
rotation
uh you can see that it that it changes
across the day and in the morning uh it
faces with or it rotates to negative
angles which means pointing towards the
east
and then as the sun goes from east to
west you go into the positive angles
which means west facing
and then eventually you go back to zero
at night time
and so since the tracker rotation is
changing that means that the tilts and
azimuths are changing to match
and like before uh we can we use this
get totally radiance function and
everything here is the same
uh except for the surface tilt and
surface azimuth and so now we have tilt
and azimuth which we just defined above
these are now time series inputs they're
they're pandas series
that match our weather and solar
position inputs
and so it's it's kind of cool that um
that pv lid is fairly agnostic to the
things that you give it uh or
meaning that that this function works
equally well with with scalar inputs as
it does with time series inputs
and if we look at how
the tracker profile changes or the the
the poa radiance changes by with a
tracker so with a fixed tilt system
uh
the poa irradiance looked more or less
like the horizontal radians but just
maybe a scaled up like maybe multiplied
by something but with trackers this is
such a different
a different thing that's going on
that you actually get better irradiance
in the morning and afternoon than you do
right at solar noon
because uh in the morning and afternoon
you're able to face directly towards the
sun a little bit better than you can at
midday for a tracking system
uh but anyways it certainly makes a very
large difference compared to just laying
your panels flat and this is really the
appeal of using trackers right who who
wants moving parts in a big expensive
system this is why you want moving parts
because it makes a huge difference in
how much radiance you can collect
okay so that's about all we have for
tutorial two
uh the next tutorial is going to be
looking at converting you know now that
we have the irradiance input to the
system actually converting that into
power output
but let's take a quick look at questions
before we start that one
cool looks like i was maybe hitting some
of these questions unintentionally
you know somebody asked um
approximately how much benefit do you
see with or without trackers and i was
trying to think of what that might be
like off the top of my head i was
thinking like maybe 20
but it really it's about broadening the
shoulders right
right
and and wow what a great question
because we happen to have an example
this is the pv lib documentation we
happen to have an example
uh
very much along these lines yeah
modeling transition game
so i'll just scroll straight to the to
the output here
this is comparing
monthly irradiance at
various tilts for a fixed tilt system
and then also a single axis tracking and
so blue is just the the horizontal
radiance at the baseline and then the y
axis here is the monthly gain so how
much extra irradiance you get with each
of these strategies
and so you can see that uh the the
brown line here is a single axis
tracking one and so yeah it's about 20
fairly consistently across the year
anybody else want to ask a question that
we already have in the in the example
gallery
always nice to see that
what can be reasons to install panels
that are not facing south other than the
center okay southern hemisphere is a
good reason
uh if you are looking at rooftop systems
like a residential on somebody's house
then you're kind of stuck with whatever
their roof is oriented at and so if the
roof is is not facing south then
probably your panels aren't going to be
either
for utility scale large-scale systems
that are built on the ground
uh much of the time they are facing
south probably the majority of fixed
solar systems
uh that are big anyways and ground
mounts are facing south
if they're in the northern hemisphere
yes northern hemisphere
um
some reasons even if they're on the
ground and you wouldn't uh have them
facing south there are some farms that
are built on
uh like landfills for example or or
terrain that's just very
weird and not flat
and if you have to match um the terrain
that you're building on to some extent
uh that that's that's really the main
reason that that comes to my mind
um
one more reason which i think of is um
certain utilities uh see
uh you know their load peaking around 3
p.m uh 3 p.m to 4 p.m so they might you
know orient their systems a little bit
towards southwest
um
but you know again
that is for fixed systems where the
modules are not rotating uh but for
trackers you know yeah typically
most of the sites uh will have south you
know will be solid facing
is there degradation of efficiency of
pbs cells over time yes
and and efficiency degrades in several
ways this is a little bit of a rabbit
hole so i'll try to
try to keep it high level
um
right there's several different ways
that degradation can happen
uh
it's not just the cell itself although
the like the semiconductor part of a pv
cell that can degrade in various ways
you also have things like the
encapsulant that it's living in inside
the module um that can degrade and kind
of browning is a common term for that
because it discolors and starts blocking
a little bit of sunlight
uh there's there's i don't know i could
you can talk all day about different
degradation mechanisms uh i think mark
said earlier that that they last that pv
systems last decades
um
and and he talked about
warranty lengths
it's common to assume
module level degradation rates at
something like 0.5 or maybe one percent
per year efficiency loss and so for
example after after one year you might
be at only 99
of the capacity that you were when it
was first installed
okay yeah let's hop over to tutorial 2.
bobby you want to take over
sure yes
[Music]
that means
[Music]
okay let me know you guys let's see my
screen
looks good okay cool uh thanks thanks
kevin uh okay so the tutorial three is
you know going to go over
a very basic model called pve watts and
what we are going to do is you know take
on the
data sets you know kevin wentworth so
the first one is we calculated basically
the plane of irradiance
and what we are going to do is uh we are
going to take that information and we
are going to calculate the
cell temperature of our pv module so
as kevin mentioned um
the performance of the efficiency of a
pv module is dependent upon its cell
temperature
and
um
you know as the cell temperature
increases you know the performance of
the models decrease um well yes before i
talk about that let me actually also you
know throw some light on the different
level different type of uh models that
are out there to you know model pv
system so the very basic models that are
out there uh typically just you know
deal with few coefficients um the pv
what model uh model which we are going
to look today uh you know these are two
coefficients uh then you can you know um
look at the electrical circuit models
which are a little bit more involved uh
they need you know more cell more
information
uh on the
modules themselves and you know
you need to basically you know set more
parameters um and then yeah the full
blown your physics based semiconductor
models are you know like extremely
detailed um but then you know they are
rarely used um just because you know
they're
you need a lot of information plus at
the same time um
it may not be
applicable for you know large pv systems
one one models so the the increase in
the accuracy may not be warranted there
um
unfortunately i'm not getting an image
over here but uh if you guys have you
know your notebooks open um you will be
seeing an image uh which is uh basically
mark's grandma's house and
it would be showing a pv system on top
of the
rooftop
you know so we are going to model
something uh close to that
so yeah as i was saying uh the
the the performance of pv module is
dependent upon its
uh temperature
and so
you know before we can calculate how
much power a pv module is going to
produce it's important for us to you
know understand how much uh like what's
the temperature of the cell however you
know measuring the cell temperature is
extremely challenging uh because the
cell temperature is actually right
in the cell you know it's it's where the
diodes are there so typically the you
know pv community like just you know
talks about the module temperature
rather than the cell temperature and the
model temperature is you know typically
a few degrees lower you know one to two
degrees celsius lower than the cell
temperature
okay so uh
you know as as as i mentioned you know
the model's power production capacity
reduces as its temperature increases
and uh typically this is you know
between like point five percent
[Music]
so 100 watt module you know
which would produce you know 100 watts
at 25 degrees celsius will probably
produce you know 95 watts uh as you know
if it's cell temperature increased by 10
degree celsius
um okay
so going through this fairly quickly uh
all right so the first
we are just importing uh the libraries
all right so what over here we are doing
is uh just reading some of the steps you
know given um
short so we are importing
um irradiance data set over here and
then we are defining a location
um
and then uh you would see that uh in
case if if somebody is not familiar with
the
time delta operation um of pandas it
just
means that you are shifting
your time index you know by certain
amount and in this we are you know
shifting
by 30 minutes so if you actually
uh the the reason why we are doing this
is
all the
uh photovoltaic
model simulations uh or typically i
should say are early based simulations
um
where you have
you know how much
when you try to model how much power is
being produced at each r
um
and one of the key important
inputs to do this is the sun position
now you can imagine you know that the
the sun
position actually changes
quite a lot between uh
you know
between two consecutive
hours so
what we are doing is over here in order
to get an average
sun position for a particular r we are
you know
changing the uh
the
the time index by 30 minutes so we are
bringing the index to the middle of the
r so that we get this sum position for
that middle point
of a given r
um
all right
and then we are defining the tilt and
the azimuth of the pv system we want to
model so in this we are saying tilt is
going to be 20 degrees
and the azimuth is 180 degrees uh which
is basically facing south
all right uh then uh we basically take
this method available in preview where
we just pass in the
you know surf surface still or like the
tilt of the model
of the modules and the azimuth of the
models
we also pass in the resource information
which you know we just read in in the
second line over here
and uh passing the sun position
and once we do that
we can get the you know total idiots
that is hitting
on the
on the on the modules basically
okay so once we know how much irradiance
is hitting the model
you know we can calculate the cell
temperature
uh all right so
let's you know just quickly discuss why
our models you know temperature
increases you know
as
as it you know starts producing power
the reason is you know
all the light that is hitting the module
does not get converted into electricity
and actually
um
a typical solar module uh as of today
has around 20
efficiency so the rest
um the rest 80 percent is you know then
converted into thermal via different
mechanisms and there's been a lot of
research going on uh to try to improve
this efficiency by reducing the but by
increasing the conversion
of light into electricity
but anything which is not converted into
electricity eventually you know gets
converted into thermal energy and this
increases the model temperature
so
purely has
uh some built-in models um
and one of the one of the very you know
kind of commonly used models out there
to model the cell temperature is the
sandia in your performance model
which takes in your
basic uh some basic empirical
coefficients to
model the temperature of of a module
based on how much light is hitting the
module and the ambient conditions
relevant to the temperature and wind
speed
so
over here we are just taking in the
parameters which are already defined in
the library
and we are just you know calling them uh
using this method
and then uh we are using the model the
sapm model you know using the irradiance
the poa irradiance we calculated before
and the temperature and the wind speed
i think i'm going for a lot of content
over here
do we have any questions at this point
uh nothing in the chat bobby okay cool
um
all right so
basically
just a quick recap till this point so
what we have done is we have taken the
uh plane of array irradiance
we calculated
and then we use that along with you know
certain parameters of a module
um
to calculate the module temperature and
just to you know give
like you know quick quick um
kind of insight into like what different
kind of parameters are available these
are the four different
categories if you will you know uh which
represents different kind of model
construction
and based upon
you know one specific module
construction you could choose you know
one of the four that are available in
pivot
and this this you know different
basically parameters are nothing but set
of coefficients which you can find on
the periodic documentation
okay so
this is this plot you basically compares
the
cell temperature of the module uh you
know versus the
um what versus the drywall or the
ambient temperature if you you know
across across a given day
or multiple days
and we can see that you know
that the
the model temperature of the cell
temperature is significantly higher you
know during the day times
um when actually the model is producing
power
and
this is very common uh the reason is you
know as we as we you know discussed
before that
the module typically you know converts
20 of the light that is hitting into
electricity so the rest you know goes
into actually
increasing the model's temperature
so it just you know goes to show how hot
the modules can get so even if you have
sub-zero
temperatures you know like negative
temperatures your model will be still
like um like 15 degree celsius
um all right so once we have calculated
the
uh modulus temperature the cell
temperature
we we are now ready to you know
calculate how much power the system
can produce so uh you know just for this
example we'll be
you know looking at a one kilowatt array
or you know one kilowatt dc capacity
um
of the
you know the pv system so the dc stands
for direct current and since models
produce you know power you know in form
of direct current uh we just call it
call that as you know dc capacity
um
and then the temperature coefficient is
assumed to be at 0.4 percent per degree
celsius that just means that you know
your
modulus efficiency is going to drop by
point four percent you know
for every degree celsius
increment
increasing your model temperature
and
uh
so p value has this you know model
called pv watts already you know built
in
which is relatively straightforward but
pretty handy
model
to
calculate how much power you know your
module is going to produce
and so
uh we are basically assuming 0.4 degree
upon 4 percentage per degree celsius of
temperature coefficient and thousand
watts or one kilowatt of
the modules installed so this this means
that your modules are going to produce
1000 watt of power
at you know at your
reference temperature condition which is
typically at 25 degree celsius
and from that point you are going to
drop
you know point four percent for every
degree celsius
you know
that there is
in you know
every degree such as
your model temperature increases so um
yeah and then basically you just pass
through by passing the irradiance data
set the cell temperature which we
calculated before
the nameplate which is a thousand watts
and
the temperature coefficient
and yeah this plot just you know shows
you how much
power that is generated uh for for the
given days
so if you actually compare this plot
with the one above
you could see
that you know
there is a fair bit of correlation
between the module temperature and the
power produced so this is the model
temperature the powerfulness
we can you know look that in
more detail with the scatter plot
so um
yeah this plot basically shows
the
array power produced uh versus the poa
irradiance
the amount of sunlight that hit the body
so one of the obvious you know things is
that you'll get more power as your
irradiance increases
uh but also now you can see that as your
ambient temperature increases
uh so you need more and more irradiance
for
for you know generating the same amount
of power
meaning if you have you know 800 watt
per meter square at 30 degree celsius
versus if you have you know 800 watt per
20 degree celsius you will end up
producing more power in cooler
conditions just because you know now
that will result in
cooler model temperatures
uh
another way to look at that same you
know kind of thought process is to
compare the area power
uh against the irradiance but this time
we are actually going to you know
have the cell temperature as the you
know
as the color coding so we can clearly
see that okay when the cell temperature
increases
your power you know your power produce
is reducing so for 800 watt per meter
square the power produced is much less
for the same areas you know you you'll
be producing this power
um
and then
yeah this is you know nothing but kind
of you know so we basically changed the
uh temperature coefficient uh from 0.4
percentage to 0.2 percentage
so
now what we are saying is basically the
model's performance is going to drop
less
you know with increasing
its temperature so meaning the
you you get you know like like a thinner
distribution if you will on the
scattered rod so your modulus
temperature is you know less affected by
or your model's performance is less
affected by its temperature
and
yep and
this thought is showing how much you
know
production you get you know for
given poi um you might notice that the
production is actually higher uh for
uh for certain months even if
even if the poi is lower and that is you
know
typically because
the temperatures are cooler in these
months and so your modules will be
actually more efficient than you know
then then there are standard conditions
so you'll end up getting no more power
so it kind of you know helps you know
smoothing out the
the profile if you will
so basically
doesn't mean that you know if you have
high poa you'll always get you know more
power
the temperature also pays significant
room
um
yeah any any questions
so far
yeah there are two great questions um
one person asked like um
what is the max
temperature difference from ambient that
uh a pv panel could experience oh good
question
um
i don't know probably i've like seen uh
fill data with model temperatures as
high as 70 degree celsius 70 75 degree
celsius
um but
yeah you know um
mark you do you have
any
i mean like you know for normal
environments like where we live i would
expect a 25 degree c difference between
ambient
you know and and operating temperature
because you know
yeah but i mean i've seen like in las
vegas i mean i don't know how high i'm
bad at celsius but like
in vegas or some or phoenix or something
like that like channels could get up to
75 seats so
that's quite a big jump from ambient you
know
yes so yep exactly i was talking about
like the model temperatures and i've
seen them to be you know like 70 75
degree celsius so if your ambient
temperature at that point was around
let's say 45 degrees celsius and you
would be seeing around 25 30 degrees
celsius difference
yeah so yeah the models can get really
hard another question somebody asked was
um
are there certain actions you can do to
i guess respond to this temperature rise
in the panels
um interesting question yeah i mean you
know
so there's
there's actually not much of research
that has happened in that direction
and you know so that there are two
things you could do
um one is look at you know passive
cooling faster cooling would probably
mean that now you need to add some kind
of fins you know in your modules
and
you know also
probably get your models exposed to more
um
linear conditions um in in a way
but um
typically you know
the the costs associated you know with
with such techniques you know are
kind of
quite high and you know they may not
want
like
you know
yeah
yeah
it's i think it's a good question but
there's not much you know
one can do now of course you know if if
you look into active cooling you know
that that is completely different
um
kind of ball game like you have
significant drop in temperatures but
i think the costs would be just
prohibitive
that's that's my first reaction
but yeah maybe you know in space
applications yeah they they
may be having you know active cooling uh
just because it's a very you know
specific system and
over there you know they can
cost and all that is kind of less um of
a variable you know abby in my
experience the only time i've seen any
kind of passive cooling on pv it was a
concentrator okay so um you know
sunpower used to have a seven sun
concentrator
and um on the back of each module
um they had fins just like you said and
then the way that uh concentrator was
designed is it had you know i don't know
several different
uh panels that were on these curved um
at the bottom of like a curved mirror
uh that focused on it
and um
and so
um they um
the the way the air flowed through those
it was a tracker and attract the sun the
way the air flowed between those curved
mirrors kind of like it was designed to
have like an airflow
that was accentuated uh by the the
curvature of the mirrors and then it
would go through those fins it was kind
of a cool design but you know they hit
the exact issue that you're talking
about like the the cost the marginal
increase of costs kills the the whole
thing
so um and i i haven't to date and you
know i i
i've been in solar for a little bit of
time you know maybe there's people with
more experience who have seen something
successful but i haven't yet seen
anything successful
but there is one cool thing what about
floating voltaics right coating voltaics
seem to
run about 10 degrees cooler
right
so maybe that's the one
i don't know
thing yeah
definitely yeah so i think yeah just for
everybody so floating vertex uh is
basically you know a system which is
constructed on top of a water body and
you know that there are you know few
different ways you could place them you
know you could directly place them
on a floating structure or you could you
know have
a rigid structure supporting uh
system but the the
i think the idea mark is talking about
is basically having water underneath
those pv systems which should you know
have a significant cooling effect
compared to the field systems on the
land
um
sorry apologies for the interruption i
just want to let you know that we have a
few minutes left oh sure yes thanks a
little under five minutes okay cool all
right uh yeah we have just you know two
more cells to go
uh so sorry i'll you take on the other
questions
after after you go over this couple of
cells so
so far what we saw was you know we
basically modeled how much power that
the modules are producing but as i said
you know the models produce power in
form of dc
uh and as you would know you know the
power we use at our homes or you know
any kind of grid applications most of
the power is you know uh ac is in form
of alternating current so there's a
component called inverter which takes
the power from models and converts that
into you know ac
so we need to convert dc into ac
and um
that means we need to model the inverter
as well
now typically we you know we actually
put more
capacity uh quote-unquote capacity on
the inverters so that you know
any efficiency loss the inverter will
have
uh will be you know kind of
covered by this more capacity we have
installed there are you know
a few other reasons as well why one
would put more module power on top of an
inverter but i i think yeah we are short
of time so excuse me for not going into
that detail
uh but
uh pv leave has this you know uh
inverter model in there where it takes
the array power which we just calculated
in the cell above and then you know the
inverter efficiency excuse me which
which is you know a static number in
this case
and
so you know finally what we get is you
know basically the ac power your pv
system is going to you know produce um
and this is showing you know how much
energy
your system produce uh in a given day
and so blue one is the ac which is the
output of the inverter and then the
orange one is
how much the model is produced and
as you'll see um
the efficiency of the inverter you know
kind of taking out some
some power
but
yeah you know and then
this is i would say this is just like a
very general introduction to pv systems
and there's really a lot more one can do
um
uh you know with pv lab like pv has
amazing
methods already built in and it's super
powerful uh to do a lot more lot more
you know so really cool stuff can be
done using people
so yeah i think i'll stop there and
probably just
take on any
announcement questions you
so i i posted in the chat
there is a link to a survey a google
survey if everybody could
if you have time to click and give us
some feedback that would be really
fantastic and helpful and then we'll
stick around on the slack channel which
is the data and tools model pv systems
and um everybody should have access to
slack so um
for me and everybody i just wanted to
thank you all for joining i hope you
learned something about pv and
give it a try try to model it
and thanks